[Music]
there are many ways to make lasagna but
no matter how it stacks up people seem
to never get enough of this classic
italian dish
popular in italy for centuries its
appeal transcends boundaries and
cultures
who anywhere can resist all those layers
of flavor
[Music]
ruffled flat noodles define lasagna they
give it structure in between the layers
the possibilities are endless
ingredients vary depending on the recipe
for a veggie lasagna things start off
with sauteed onions seasoned with pepper
and salt
they add pureed tomatoes to the pungent
mix
blade stir the ingredients as they
simmer in this steam heated mixer
and in no time they have a full body
tomato sauce
they pump the tomato sauce into lasagna
tubs this saucy base is the first layer
of flavor but it also serves a practical
purpose preventing the noodles from
sticking to the bottom of the tray
during baking
workers arrange the broad and crinkled
lasagna noodles over the sauce
these noodles have been made from a
blend of whole grain and semolina
flowers for a texture that's firm yet
tender
now for the filling ingredients this
factory lasagna will be made of roasted
organic vegetables
they include chunks of broccoli and
uniformly minced peppers onions carrots
zucchini and mushrooms
they load the sliced and diced veggies
into the next steam-heated mixer
the blades swing into action to stir the
ingredients as they brown in oil this
causes the natural sugars to break down
and the vegetables to become sweeter
creamy mozzarella cheese will offset the
sugary taste of the veggies
they add the caramelized veggies the
shredded mozzarella and more pasta
noodles building the layers of flavor
and there's a lot more to come
[Music]
over in another steam-heated mixer a
combination of milk oil and rice flour
is on a low boil
paddles distribute the ingredients and
the sauce begins to thicken
shredded monterey jack and parmesan
cheeses will enhance the creaminess and
add another dimension of flavor
[Music]
next a serious dash of nutmeg and
another one of salt spices it up
[Music]
and after more stirring action the white
sauce is velvety smooth and
substantially thicker
meanwhile a worker shovels crusts into a
grinder the crusts are broken pieces
from a pizza production line and they've
been dried to a specific consistency so
they should grind up nicely
a spiraling blade turns the crust into
uniform crumbs a classic lasagna topping
adding a bit of crunch to the recipe
[Music]
with these final ingredients they're
ready to pile it on thick
as the layering process continues this
meal really comes together
the cream sauce and breadcrumbs are the
finishing touches
with numerous sous chefs involved things
happen a whole lot faster here than on
the home front
they assemble 48 single serving lasagna
dishes per minute at this factory
[Music]
then place them on trays and transfer
them to a specialized freezer
this is a blast freezer which is also
known as a shock freezer
it brings down the temperature of foods
very rapidly preserving the flavor
[Music]
on the next shift they remove the
lasagnas from the freezer it's time to
wrap up this meal
the lasagnas ride a conveyor through a
curtain of cellophane
an automated system heat seals the wrap
around the trays
things move swiftly to prevent thawing
[Music]
they package 75 lasagnas per minute on
this line and then it's back in the
freezer to await shipping
once something only mama made now
workers and machines team up to mass
produce this traditional comfort food
so at meal time one only has to pop the
frozen lasagna in the oven and then
manja
[Music]
you